when we kissed i was just like
kim kardashian dishes on her first kiss
with pete davidson and his bde
yeah more on that in just a second it's
really lit and fun and crazy the 41 year
old reality star and the 28 year old
comedian first started dating after she
hosted saturday night live back in
october where the two made headlines for
puckering up in this aladdin sketch
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
well the kkw beauty founder recently
revealed that that was their first kiss
kim is this the first time you kissed
pete yes
and in a new chat with amanda hirsch on
deer media's not skinny but not fat
podcast kim goes into detail about that
first kiss revealing it gave her a
little zing when we kissed i was just
like hmm really but like a stage kiss
yeah it was a stage kiss but it was like
still like a little
zing you know
it wasn't anything like a super crazy
feeling and kim adds that smooch with
pete was the first time she kissed
someone who isn't her ex kanye west in a
decade and she wasn't sure if the spark
she felt with pete was just in her head
i was just like hmm and then i was like
wow i really haven't kissed anyone else
in 10 years so maybe i'm just like being
stupid and it's just nothing and then a
few days later
i was like hmm
there is some bde action
yeah so if you don't know what bde is
let us help you out bde is an acronym
for big energy if you have confidence
but aren't cocky that's bde yep of
course the snl star's rumored bde has
been a thing since his 2018 split from
his ex ariana grande who referenced pete
in her music video for thank you next
yeah right
there
as for kim and pete they made their love
insta official last month and while the
king of staten island star didn't film
with kim for season one of the
kardashians kim recently told variety
she's not opposed and she will open up
about all the juicy details of their
romance this is a relationship that i
don't think anybody saw coming who are
you texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
and when eti sat down with the skim's
founder and her famous family to chat
about their new hulu series she couldn't
help but gush about her man
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him um
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just hang
out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing now the goal is
finding someone to do nothing with it's
the best because you can do everything
with totally but it's crazy to be
distracted with people you can be with
anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing and pete he has the
kardashian stamp of approval i love that
he's
kind and really really thoughtful he's
the most thoughtful person
and i love
yeah and i love the chemistry that kim
and him have together it's really sweet
i thought she said the chemistry he was
like okay chemistry chemistry
[Music]